Marco I I don't know if you were a
terrible child but do you know the story
I'm talking about where like you do not
win any awards for being a good daughter
there are many stories where I don't
know what I was not a great daughter I
would I am forever in my mom's debt
because I was such a brat I feel really
bad about it tell us the story about
when you were on your computer and she
wanted your help
oh yes she yes okay so I I was on MSN
obviously the most we moved out like you
know out in the sticks and often snakes
would get into the house and you know it
wasn't a big deal but you just have to
like chase him around and get it out
it's kind of time-consuming in an
annoying and so my mom yelled out and
she was like can you come help me
there's this snakes really big like I
can't get it on my own can you come help
me and I was like I'm so busy mom no I
can't like just being a brat I was gonna
missing and she was like oh I just like
hey you should please and all it's like
be gone and she was she was going for
like ten minutes and I was like oh she's
been gone for ages and then I like got
up from the computer I could hear like
this and also oh god what's happening
and I see mom she's like made it halfway
down the stairs and the snake she'd
tried to like pick this big Python up
with her but with a broom and a stick
but it had wound its way up around her
arm and was going around her neck but I
would never be able to know I know I'm
painting a bad picture it's really not
bad but
another poisonous state but they don't
strangle you you just want to give it
something else to climb so you gotta
stick with something it starts weaving
its way around that and then you can
transfer its weight and you grab it
behind its head you grab it behind it
would your mother okay yes here's fine
so bad and I tried not to be such a brat
when Mom asked for help in the future I
kind of did it a lesson learned very
good
[Music]